so a week ago we got the Avengers
in-game Super Bowl big game TV spot that
had nothing but new footage in it it was
a real treat for us but now everybody is
starting to wonder are there a few
scenes in this TV spot that may not be
all that they seem to be after all the
trailers and the TV spots that we got
for Avengers infinity war turned out to
not be 100% accurate this included some
fake scenes such as the one that showed
all of the avengers including the Hulk
running through the woods in Wakanda
together hearing characters say lines
that were never actually in the movie
such as Stannis's line fun isn't
something one considers when balancing
the universe but this does put a smile
on my face and some scenes that randomly
added things into scenes that weren't in
there and took some things and
characters out of scenes that were
actually there so needless to say the
Russo brothers and Marvel go to great
lengths to keep everything about the
movie as secretive as possible so in
this video I'm going to talk about some
scenes that could be intentional
misdirection from the Russo brothers and
just a quick reminder I started a new
giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets so you can go see Captain Marvel
or Avengers in game in IMAX if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite character that could be a
superhero or a villain so there are a
few things you have to keep in mind when
it comes to the Avengers in-game
trailers and TV spots that we get that
have new footage in it and one of them
is that all these trailers and new
footage that we get for Avengers in game
will most likely only be from the first
15 to 20 minutes of the movie and the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
said this himself in an interview you're
never gonna show us much past say the
first 15 or 20 minutes of the movie is
that kind of strategy is that somewhat
accurate I call it somewhat accurate
yeah I think I think as was the case
with a lot of our films this one in
particular you know being able to
generate excitement without giving away
any of the many many many many secrets I
originally thought that he was saying
that the trailer is somewhat accurate
but what he's really saying is that the
footage that we see in the trailers is
only going to be from the first 15 to 2
minutes of the movie that's somewhat
accurate so keep in mind that most of
these scenes if they're real are only
from the first 15 to 20 minutes of the
movie and another thing you need to
remember is what the Russo brothers had
to say about filming fake scenes for
Avengers infinity war in an interview
with the happy sad confused podcast Joe
Russo explained the fake scenes in the
infinity war trailers he said we use all
the material that we have at our
disposal to create a trailer we look at
the trailer as a very different
experience than the movie and I think
audiences are so predictive now that you
have to be very smart about how you
craft a trailer because an audience can
watch a trailer and basically tell you
what's gonna happen in the film we
consume too much content so at our
disposal are lots of different shots
that aren't in the movie that we can
manipulate through CG to tell a story
that we want to tell specifically for
the purpose of the trailer and not for
the film so the Risser brothers
themselves say that they intentionally
put scenes that are not in the movies in
the trailers or they use CG to
manipulate scenes to make them different
than they actually are
so what scenes in the New Avengers end
game TV spot may not be 100% accurate or
not even in the movie well for starters
the first 15 seconds of the new TV spot
may not be in the movie at all all of
the footage from the first 15 seconds is
trying to show us that some time has
passed between thanasis snap and where
the Avengers are at now but some of the
other scenes in this TV spot sort of
contradict that fact for example we have
the scene of Tony and nebula working
really hard to fix the benitar this has
to happen right after the snap because
Tony and nebula are on Titan and they
need to leave and get back home to earth
and we know that Iron Man has ran out of
food and water so we know that not much
as time has passed between the snap and
where the Avengers are at now so the
first 15 seconds of the new TV spot
including Steve in the support group
could in fact be misdirection the next
scene that sticks out the most that may
not be 100% accurate is where some of
the Avengers are outside of the Avengers
facility looking to the sky it seems
like somebody is missing from this scene
there's an odd gap here that could be a
hero that's not actually in this scene
perhaps it could be Captain Marvel or
maybe Tony Stark is already back on
earth and Captain Marvel is arriving
obviously Captain Marvel being there at
the
facility or Tony arriving back on earth
and being at the Avengers facility in
the first 15 to 20 minutes of the movie
is something that the Russo brothers
would want to keep a secret so it is
possible that there is a character in
this scene that has been removed they
did this for Avengers infinity war so it
wouldn't really be a big surprise if
they did it for this scene in Avengers
endgame another scene where this same
thing could be possible is this scene
with war machine and ant-man there could
be a person that is in there in the
movie but they've removed for the
trailer then we have the scene with what
appears to be Captain America strapping
his shield to his arm
knowing the Russo brothers this may not
be Captain America holding the shield
although the hands in this scene do look
like Captain America's hands and the
gloves are definitely Captain America's
as well this is a pretty big scene to
show in a trailer this shows us that
Captain America gets his shield back
which will be a pretty big part in the
movie and considering the fact that the
Russo brothers said that they don't want
us to know what's going to happen in the
movie it's strange that they put this in
the trailer so this could be intentional
misdirection as well and the last seen
in the TV spot that could be
misdirection is the scene where all of
the Avengers are walking through the
Avengers facility this whole scene right
here with the Avengers walking could be
faked if you look in the first Avengers
in-game teaser trailer that we got this
exact scene is in that trailer the
camera pans to a different direction but
it's the exact same shot and there are
no Avengers walking in that scene so
this entire scene in the New Avengers TV
spot could be fake it could be CGI or
the Avengers endgame teaser trailer
could be fake and they CGI'd those
characters out of the scene but if this
scene does end up being real there is
something odd about it there's a weird
gap between Rhodey and ant-man if you
look at the rest of the Avengers they're
all walking pretty closely to each other
except for that gap between Rhodey and
ant-man this could actually be Professor
Hulk that's supposed to be right there
but they CGI'd him out if you look at
the person in the back you can't really
make him out it looks like it could be
Bruce Banner but it could be Hawkeye and
it could actually be professor Hulk in
that empty spot because if the Avengers
are walking to go and start their
mission natasha has probably already
gone out and found Clint so that would
mean he would be with the rest of the
Avengers there
that could be misdirection that could be
edited or may not even be in the movie
we'll have to wait till the movie comes
out to find out but let me know what you
all think if you think that some of
these scenes aren't 100% accurate let me
know what you think they are let me know
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe comment down
below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers and
game as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you